A hallucination is a sensation without a stimulus.
But why do hallucinations occur?
To answer that we have to look at perception itself.
We think of perception as a passive process--
an input arrives and is received.
But actually, perception is more like a guess
of what is out there in our environment.
It’s the result of sensory input, sure,
but also another component that may be
just as important: Our prior beliefs, or expectations.
Some scientists think that hallucinations occur
when strong beliefs create an imbalance
with sensory input.
To see if they could witness this overpowering
of external input by beliefs researchers created
a game that caused auditory hallucinations
and observed the effects on brains and behavior.
Their experiment is a twist on Pavlovian training.
Whereas Pavlov’s dog learned to associate
food with sound--Instead, the scientists trained
human players to associate sight with sound.
In the game, a checkerboard flashes on
and a tone is played simultaneously.
With enough repetitions, participants start to expect
to hear the sound when they see the image,
even when the sound isn’t actually played.
They were played the tone at different intensities
and sometimes no tone at all.
As the game went on,
there were more and more no-tone events.
The participants were asked to press a button
each time they heard the tone.
They were also told to press longer
based on their confidence in their judgment.
When players were presented a checkerboard
without the tone but still pressed the button,
that was considered a hallucination.
Four different groups were selected to play:
A control group that didn’t have
a history of hallucinations or psychosis
Daily hallucinators with no diagnosed psychotic illness.
Non-hallucinators with psychotic illness.
And finally, daily hallucinators with a psychotic illness.
Crunching the data, researchers found that
all participants experienced conditioned hallucinations
during the game.
The people who already heard voices were
the most susceptible to the effect
and were the most confident they heard tones
when none were actually played.
Brain scans conducted during the game showed
what regions were activated
when conditioned hallucinations occurred.
Researchers then devised a model for hallucination
that provided different weights for beliefs and inputs.
Fitting the behavioral data into the model,
they found that hallucinators do overweight beliefs
and this correlates with regions of the brain
that we know relate to perceptual beliefs.
Those with psychosis were less able
to update their beliefs,
which corresponded with activity in the hippocampus
and cerebellum, which typically guide our memories
and our sensory and motor predictions
about our bodies in the world.
The model suggests that when players w/out psychosis
were trained in the game, they formed a strong belief
that the sound would coincide with the checkerboard
but as the game progressed, they caught on
that more no tone trials were being played,
because they were able to update their beliefs.
The players with psychosis, on the other hand,
had trouble adapting as the game changed.
The nexts steps are to use larger sample sizes
and machine learning tactics to further distinguish
between voice-hearers with and without psychosis.
The hope is that researchers could diagnose
if a hallucinator is on a path to psychosis
and suggest more targeted treatments in the future.